[موسيقى]
أحمر برتقالي أصفر
أخضر أزرق نيلي بنفسجي فوشيا
كارنيليان
شارتريوس على مدى ستة عقود على
العرش
، أصبح أسلوب الملكة إليزابيث الثانية
مرتبطًا بحجب الألوان الزاهية
ونقوش الإيماءات الدقيقة إلى
الصور الظلية العصرية في العصور
الماضية أفسحت المجال لمظهر علامتها التجارية الخاصة
في السنوات اللاحقة ،
على الرغم من مكانتها الصغيرة ، كانت تبرز
وسط حشد من الناس ،
فهي تعتقد أنه من واجبها حتى يتمكن أولئك
الذين تجمعوا من اكتشافها
وفي اللقطات الجماعية
نادرًا ما يتغلب عليها أفراد العائلة المالكة
[الموسيقى]
لن أتمكن أبدًا من ارتداء البيج لأن لا
أحد يعرف من
أنا الملكة ذكرت ذات مرة أن
الملابس يمكن أن تكون أيضًا وسيلة
للتواصل وجلالتها هي
أستاذة في الدبلوماسية التجميلية
تستخدم الألوان والرموز لتكريم
الأمة
أو للحفاظ على الحياد لإكمال
هذه
الملحقات المطابقة المخصصة لمظلات فولتون للطيور
مع مظلات متعددة  - حواف ملونة
تسمح لها برؤيتها حتى عندما تمطر
أوشحة حريرية متعددة الألوان من
ماركة فاخرة فرنسية
rmes وبالطبع
العديد من القبعات العديدة التي يضعها الناس حتى يراهنون على
اللون الذي ستكون عليه قبعتها
في حدث Royal Ascot السنوي
[تصفيق]
ما ترتديه الملكة ويجب أن يكون
مناسبًا
أنجيلا كيلي كانت ترتدي الملكة
منذ عام 1994.
معها  تحتفظ بسجل
لكل زي مصنوع حسب الطلب
يختبرون المواد
والتخفيضات للارتداء ويعملون على
البحث عن الطقس المحلي
والعادات للرحلات
وفقًا لكيلي ،
يمكن ارتداء ملابس مقتصده عدة
مرات وتستمر لعقود
بينما تظل الملكة فوق الموسم
أزياء لا يزال بإمكانها تحديد
اتجاهات الموضة في عام 2016 ، ألهمت مجموعتها المتوهجة ذات اليوم الأخضر
هاشتاغ ، حيث
أن خزانة ملابس الملكة ليست ملونة دائمًا.
الملابس المحايدة وكذلك الملابس السوداء من الرأس إلى أخمص القدمين
مخصصة بشكل أساسي للمناسبات الاحتفالية
ولكن الأحذية أو ملابسها الشهيرة
غالبًا ما يمكن مشاهدة أكياس الملابس في هذا
الظل
المعقول والأنيق الفخم
والمناسب ، تعتبر خزانة ملابس الملكة عنصرًا حيويًا
ومطمئنًا في شخصيتها العامة ،
وهي مظهر مميز تم
تصميمه بعناية طوال فترة خدمة
[الموسيقى]
[تصفيق]